children ages 5 to 11 may be able to get
coveted vaccines as soon as tomorrow
that's because an independent cdc
advisory panel will meet this morning to
consider authorizing pfizer's pediatric
vaccine it would then be up to cdc
director dr rochelle wolinski to give
the final a-ok for some 28 million
american kids to get vaccinated but
here's the thing only 27 percent of
parents say they will vaccinate their
kids right away another third say
they'll wait and see how it's working
before making a decision and another
third say they will definitely not
vaccinate their kids at all
but even families who want the vaccine
face another challenge
it's a classic one fear of needles
senior medical correspondent dr taran
rula is here to show us how one program
uses science and technology to help
families reduce their fear and anxiety
can they do that tara please help us
they can gail king
good morning to all of you
i'm listening with both ears so i'm
scared an estimated 63 percent of
children are afraid of needles and so
are many of their parents one study
found the fear is so bad some kids avoid
routine vaccines but as i learned there
are proven strategies to reduce pain and
give kids more control over the
vaccination process
azariah banister likes to think he's got
super powers
but when it comes to getting his
upcoming flu shot he needs a little help
your smart brain knows that signal isn't
important to you right now meet supermeg
a chatbot that helps kids overcome their
fears about needles they are doing the
poke to help you be healthy created by
the meg foundation a non-profit focused
on pain management super meg guides
nine-year-old azariah through the
vaccine process everyone does better
when they know what to expect teaching
him breathing and distraction techniques
so when he arrives at a nova children's
hospital in virginia do you want to look
or do you want to look away or look at
mom azariah is ready
i took a deep breath and looked away
science shows the source of pain lies in
the brain pain is not just about the
needle going in the skin it's about the
anxiety jody thomas is a pediatric
psychologist and ceo of the meg
foundation
kids often feel like they don't have a
choice to get that poke so as much
choice as we can give them which arm do
we want that poke in which toy do you
want to bring do you want to sit on my
lap how does the debate that obviously
children have been hearing from the
adults around them complicate the
preparation for the vaccine rollout to
young children kids are of course
hearing everything they always do we're
hearing kids talk about that they want
to get this vaccination because it not
only keeps themselves healthy but it's
helping take care of others and that's
an incredibly powerful message for kids
they're doing something good for the
world i did it
for azariah he plans to use his new
superpowers for the next big shot his
covid vaccine it's a pandemic and it's
very fatal they don't want to get sick
very cute
boy brave i like it yes yeah so what
what's so tricky here for parents is
they don't want to trivialize fear of
vaccines they don't want to say oh
you're fine don't worry about it but at
the same time
you don't want to recognize it too much
because then you can feed into it so
what's the balance how do you find it
well there are a lot of proven
strategies and you heard in the piece
one big one is really just finding ways
to give your child control to put them
in the driver's seat of this process and
that starts with really making a plan
usually one to two days ahead so as dr
thomas said to me you don't want to show
up for and find out two minutes before
that you have to have the biggest
meeting of your life right you don't
want to tell your kids in the parking
lot by the way we're going to get a
vaccine so you want to think of this
like game day right so ask them how they
want to have the shot for example so my
nine-year-old wanted to watch my
five-year-old didn't when she got their
flu vaccine so giving them those choices
is important language is important so
you actually heard in the piece she
specifically used the word poke and not
shot yeah also saying things like we're
going to go get some magic medicine to
keep us healthy not necessarily a
vaccine yes then there's things you can
do around i like using the word
superpower too yeah
superhero
around the time of the shot so you know
comfort positioning there are ways to
hold your child touch holding hands i
know my husband likes that when he gets
his flu shot
and then things like location very sweet
by the way
yes um you may not want to take your
child to a mass vaccination site where
there are crying kids maybe set up a
specific appointment where they wait in
the car maybe you get a text message
time to come in distraction so we all
know children who come home and they
have bruises and you say how did you get
that they say i don't know because it's
easy to ignore pain when you're focused
on something else so bringing a screen a
toy is not a bad idea and then my
favorite is rewards so my mom used to do
this for us when we were kids i had no
idea this was really a strategy and now
we do it for our kids because it takes
their mind off of what's happening
what's the reward what are you doing so
we say you can go to the toy store and
pick out something very small like under
five dollars
but i like the reward you brought busy
beam not sure what he does but i like it
already how does this work so it's
amazing that parents don't know about
this and unfortunately it's not routine
in a lot of pediatrician's office but
this is buzzy b this is a vibrating tool
that you can basically bring with you it
also has these wings that you can freeze
and so what happens is you basically
turn it on tony i don't know if you want
to feel but it's oh yeah it vibrates a
little bit gently vibrating you put it
over the site of wherever the poke is
going to be for about 30 to 60 seconds
and then when they're ready to get the
poke you move it up above it leave it on
for that time when they're getting the
poke and basically the vibration causes
this traffic jam of pain signals so that
you don't sense the pain as much of
course the ice works as well so you know
really really great tool and also
numbing cream like this is something you
can buy over the counter that a lot of
parents don't even know about and put it
on your child before you take them
you're so considerate they said tara
brought this for you
i gave you the ladybug and that's my
favorite she's scared of me that's where
she's yes and i'm keeping it too that's
my thank you
appreciate you doctor
yes i got all those notes i'm gonna pass
it along to the wifey